we free ish we're not free signs chance
and heartfelt songs shape these calls
for change on a monumental day in our
nation's history we just need more
change the black lives matter movement
has continued to demand justice here in
Las Vegas and all around the world but
Friday's demonstration shared a new
level of poignance and pain as the
community celebrated Juneteenth I just
hoped that that wakes up a lot of people
that didn't know that this was an actual
holiday for us to go and read about it
do research of June 19 1865 marks the
day when all American slaves officially
gained their freedom two and a half
years after President Lincoln's
Emancipation Proclamation
now 155 years later those marching say
there's still so much work to do and
they're not moving on this message
I hope it lights a fire and more people
to take more action and I hope that it
sparks people to vote they say they
won't stop fighting back until everyone
experiences true equality if I got to be
85 out here marching I will
now no word on how many were arrested
tonight but we did see several
demonstrators and handcuffs on the Las
Vegas Strip
now police also intervened this
afternoon confiscating several signs
that were wooden they said those are not
allowed in rallies or protests here in
Las Vegas and they did cite a Nevada
statute for now reporting live sasha
Loftus 8 news now